oui mais là
mais ce passionné
absolument on l'a découvert à cannes ça
a été un énorme choc
tout simplement parce que c'est un
terrain très très particulier infiniment
plus mélancolique infiniment plus
onirique que ce qu'il a pu faire jusqu'à
présent
et c'est une espèce de balade entre les
tondre un what if
un film on se dit et si et qu'est ce qui
se serait passé si nos deux héros brad
pitt et leonardo dicaprio qui se promène
dans un hollywood en l'occurrence non
pas très réaliste mais très proche des
souvenirs de tarantino qu'est ce qui se
serait passé si ses deux chiens dans ce
jeu de quilles avait tout changé et
c'est on va dire un amour de cinéma et
une promesse de rêve je trouve assez
assez incroyable ah oui alors pour une
fois il est tellement tendre alors il
continue à faire évidemment de l'humour
il ya des scènes de faux film de faux
série télé qui sont extraordinaires sans
mourir de rire
mais il ya une telle tendresse pour cet
hollywood là et en plus l'hollywood un
peu des types à côté c'est à dire les
mets qui ont pas complètement réussi à
faire leur carrière et qui ont fait
plutôt du poney que du grand cheval dans
les westerns voyait ou et où les
cascadeurs qu'on voit toujours derrière
où les types qui tombe des trains on
sait pas qui c'est à ce genre de ce
genre de hollywood la ilaha illa ça il a
vraiment une telle affection pour eux
que ça mais ça transpire à l'écran est
alors mais brad pitt
brad pitt sur un toit qui répare une
antenne de télé qui évidemment est cassé
voyez le symbole l'antenne de télé cassé
et ya un acteur qui monte sur un toit
pour tenter de la réparer
eh ben ce moment là j'ai pas très bien
son tee shirt qui peuvent masquer ce qui
est fort aussi c'est que il utilise le
montage alterné qui défigurent de son
cinéma vous savez on a deux scènes en
même temps et ils poussent très loin
avec le tournage d'un western pas très
bon et puis une visite dans le dans le
ranch de la famille c est du coup il ya
un côté d'un côté il ya un truc un peu
faux et de l'autre brûlant intense et et
c'est ce mélange là le sim c'est
exactement ce que vous dites c'est à
dire que c'est à la fois un film joyeux
et profondément mais leur mélancolique
c'est un film très beau il ya quelque
chose que je trouve incroyable pendant
les deux premières heures du film c'est
la reconstitution 1969 c'est une des
plus belles reconstitution au cinéma que
j'ai vu de l'histoire
on a l'impression que rien n'est faux
tout est là tout a été filmé au présent
dans l'instant est dans le moment vous
êtes dithyrambique évident
marc craquer mais il n'a pas encore
parlé et c'est important la troupe
lepage et trouve le brillant rutilant
ludique après moi je t'offre la fin un
peu problématique sur le sort fait aux
personnages voilà parce qu'on est dans
le tarantino qui m
l'hémoglobine l'hémoglobine pardon et
moi yade va là ça me met un peu mal à
l'aise
frédéric un mot de la fin ce que je
trouve le plus incroyable c'est la
reconstitution en fait des tournages de
films de série b que tournai le
personnage joué par dicaprio il ya
aucune ironie pour une fois chez
tarantino aucune ironie pour une fois
c'est au premier degré et il montre
vraiment comment les choses qu'ils
construiraient l'italie en italie une
très belle séquence eia il ya une scène
parce que quand même ça parle de sharon
tate on sait tous il ya une scène
absolument magnifique
sharon tate rance dans une salle de
cinéma ah oui elle est toute seule et
elle se regarde dans un film où on sent
que elle se dit que peut-être avec ce
film là elle va devenir une star et
cette actrice est mise en abyme cette
actrice regardant dans toute seule à
l'écran avec un espèce de sourires
angéliques
c'est d'une beauté avec ses grandes
bottes blanches la très très années 60
et tout et c'est merveilleux ça c'est
vraiment ça brise le coeur pour voir
once upon tyne haut avec leonardo
dicaprio brad pitt margot robbie il
faudra attendre le 14 août
allez-y évidemment en cadillac